let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
okay number one here from the daily wire
law enforcement officials in
philadelphia have reportedly launched an
investigation into a vehicle that was
discovered containing explosives and
suspicious items
which comes as the city is rocked by
left-wing anti-police riots and
widespread looting abc6 reported
action news has learned that police
recovered propane tanks torches and
possible dynamite sticks from this van
the bomb squad is on the scene at this
hour city officials say at least
200 businesses many of them already
struggling the missile pandemic
were the targets of massive looting
across the city over the last couple of
nights
to assist police an undetermined number
of pennsylvania national guard troops
will soon be arriving in the city but we
haven't seen them yet
or at least we hadn't seen through the
first two two nights of of rioting we
didn't see any national guard
um and very few police actually out
there too philadelphia mayor jim kenney
slammed those who were looting and
writing saying that the destruction of
property will not be allowed
well it's already been allowed we just
got through 200 businesses that have
been targeted
we're not going to allow you people to
do what you've already done and continue
to do
we won't allow it um he said the looting
has taken place that takes place that
has taken place is distressing
and it's clear that many of these folks
are taking advantage of the situation
harming our businesses and communities
doing a great disservice to those who
want to protest the death of walter
wallace jr
well nobody's protesting the death of
walter wallace jr no one is concerned
about that
that's got nothing to do with anything
that's happening
um nor should anyone be protesting it
because he was charging at police with a
knife
and so there's no injustice here there's
no moral outrage it's a sad thing
anytime someone dies
it's not a moral outrage though nothing
nothing illegal or unlawful or unjust
took place
uh and then he continues from there so
he he um he calls it distressing
great very coming down really hard on
them
this is very distressing i'm very
distressed by this
you know reading this it reminds you
actually
in some ways how amazing it really is
that the rioting has not for the most
part escalated so far
into larger scale terrorist attacks like
bombings now this is all terrorism in my
view
black lives matter domestic terrorist
organization i think they would fit that
categorization to a to a t but this is
politically
motivated violence
and the leaders of black lives matter
the people out in the streets they're
they're pretty explicit about that if
you listen to them
but in terms of large-scale attacks like
bombings we haven't
seen that yet not yet
though it seems like from this it's
trending this way and i can tell you
that if more democrats are put
in power people who coddle these
domestic terrorists encourage them
give them room to destroy in the
immortal words of the former
mayor of baltimore we're going to see
that escalation because bad guys
they'll do whatever you allow them to do
you sit back and let them loot
they'll loot give them even more liberty
to commit crimes and more violent crimes
they'll do that too
number two here's a story from a few
days ago that i haven't had a chance to
talk about
until now but i can't uh but i have to
talk about it i can't just
let this one be article in newsweek it
says ahead of thanksgiving next month
california governor gavin newsom and the
california department of public health
released new safety guidelines for all
private gatherings amid the ongoing
coven 19 pandemic
the new rules come with strict
restrictions that aim to help reduce the
risk of spreading infection
um and uh here's what the statement says
from the cdph the california department
of public health
gatherings are defined as social
situations that bring people together
from different households at the same
time in a single space or place
that's good thank you for defining
gatherings for us
all gatherings must include no more than
three households
including hosts and guests and must be
held outdoors
lasting for two hours or less the longer
the duration the risk of transmission
increases
gatherings that occur outdoors are
significantly safer than indoor
gatherings all gatherings must be held
outside
attendees may go inside to use restrooms
very merciful i thank you for that
they could be telling us to go just pee
in our in our in you know if you're
visiting your
your uh in-laws or something they could
tell you to go pee in the bushes
and but no they're allowing you to go
inside so thank you so much to our
benevolent rulers i
i am i am so grateful
uh so you maybe go going to use the
restroom the new rules state that
those at the gathering may remove their
face coverings briefly to eat or drink
as long as they stay at least six feet
away from everyone outside their own
household
and put their face covering back on as
soon as they are done with the activity
uh it also mentions that now that of
course no singing or shouting or any
other form of
loud communication will be allowed so
democrats in california
talk about talk about the war on family
i could have included this i was saving
it for here
they are telling you how many of your
own family members
you can have at your home where on your
property you're allowed to meet with
them
how long you may be with them what you
may do
together while while you are with them
and also that you have to wear a mask
you can lift it up to take a drink but
make sure you're six feet away so
every time you want to take a drink you
have to run away from everybody lift up
your mask take the drink
and then go back this
is uh this is almost unbelievable
i i have to tell you when i first saw
this online i
i'm not even saying this to be funny i
really thought it might be a parody i
thought
because someone had screenshotted some
of the the stuff like some of the the um
some of the passages from this article
and i think that's how i first saw it on
twitter and i
i really thought it was from babylon b
but no this is very real
uh and of course it goes without saying
should go without saying they have
absolutely no authority to do this at
all they have
no authority and no power no legitimate
power to tell you
uh how many family members you can have
at your own house
i mean the the california department of
public health
what the hell authority do you have to
make these decisions
for me and what i can do in my own home
number three if you needed more reasons
to not support the girl scouts
aside from the fact that their cookies
taste like graham crackers that have
been sitting in your grandmother's
pantry since 1987.
aside from that here's another one the
girl scouts tweeted this yesterday a
note of congratulations to amy coney
barrett for becoming the fifth woman
appointed to the supreme court now
that's not the reason to not support
them that's fine
okay that's a you know very nonpartisan
it's a
tweet saying congratulations there's a
picture of all five women that have been
uh appointed to the supreme court and uh
that's it
non-political nonpartisan fine but
leftists of course were upset about this
because any any positive acknowledgement
of amy coney barrett or any other
conservative is verboten his anathema
uh heretical you can't do it they can't
stomach it they can't allow it so
they ganged up and and bullied the girl
scouts into deleting
and essentially apologizing for this
post and saying that uh you know it was
a mistake to put it up because
they didn't want to be political they
weren't trying to be political they're a
non-political organization
but then shocker of shockers here girl
scouts have tweeted in the past
congratulating liberal female supreme
court justices
like sonia sotomayor and those tweets
are still up
so those apparently are not political it
becomes political all of a sudden
when you're congratulating a
conservative right so what are the girl
scouts teaching girls here what's the
lesson
they're teaching girls to cave to peer
pressure
back down to the mob apologize for doing
things that aren't wrong
just because it made someone's tummy
hurt and they complained about it
and conformed to the crowd that's that's
what they're being taught
basically all of the exactly wrong sorts
of lessons
that's what you get from the girl scouts
number four i'm going to show you
something
speaking of things that seem like a joke
at first i'm going to show you this this
is 100
real i assure you uh but with no setup
here it is without context watch
as of today there have been 38 160 cases
of covid19 in oregon
with 390 new cases being reported today
sadly we are also reporting three deaths
today
bringing the statewide total for covid19
related deaths
to 608.
now for those listening to the podcast
the audio probably didn't sound too bad
you're probably listening to that thing
okay what's the problem
um it sounded like maybe some kind of
health official announcing
covid daily death numbers which is what
it was
that's a senior official with the oregon
health authority
making this announcement about covet
problem and what you can't see if you're
only listening
is that the woman is actually wearing
clown
makeup she is dressed like a clown
to tell us who died from covid
this was apparently supposed to be some
sort of halloween thing okay
but that's not an excuse i mean just
because it's going to be halloween soon
that doesn't mean you could just wear a
costume anytime you want
regardless of the circumstance how would
you feel if you were going in for heart
surgery
and your heart surgeon right before you
went under from the
the anesthesia you see your heart
surgeon coming in
dressed like freddy krueger to celebrate
the occasion
what it's halloween relax or what if you
uh went to identify
a relative's remains at the the
coroner's office
and the woman there is dressed like a
sexy vampire
it's just it's not appropriate for the
occasion
and i would say costumes really are
never appropriate for adults it never
really works but especially not in a
professional context though i also have
to say
the fact that organ has literal clowns
running their pandemic response
does not surprise me at all okay number
five here's another um
addition to everyone's favorite genre of
tick-tock videos
that would be the genre of uh women
having mental breakdowns on camera over
news events
a lot of these usually this is done in
the car which i think actually explains
a lot by the way about women drivers
that this is where they do their their
this is this is where they have their
emotional collapses
um that doesn't surprise me a lot either
but
here's something a little bit different
this is a mental breakdown in the
bathtub
uh this is a few days old but it's still
good stuff still worth playing here it
is check it out
don't mind me i'm in the bath but
while i've been here i got a
notification
that that uh
amy cody parent was
officially converted to the supreme
court
i didn't think i would be this affected
by it
but i'm scared i'm scared for me
other women people
who need help everyone except
white men so um
please vote next week let's try to
do something you know i see videos like
this and there's this hopeful part of me
that says this has
to be parody it has to be a joke and
maybe it is i don't know there's
obviously planning and forth
forethought and and editing even that
goes into this
why would someone do this except as a
joke
you're crying in a bathtub that's
humiliating this is a humiliating
embarrassing moment in your life
why would you intentionally document it
and spread it online for others to see
if i ever cried at a bathtub if i ever
took a bath
at all i would be embarrassed but uh if
i was
crying in a bathtub
i think the last thing i would ever want
to do is tell everybody about it
it would be a shameful moment that i
would keep locked inside
myself for my entire life never to be
spoken of to anyone
ever so why are you putting your own
embarrassing eminently mockable moments
online this is what people do on tick
tock it's sort of like a form of
of self-cyber bullying they're cyber
bullying themselves
by putting this stuff out there it's
like if you peed your pants and then
immediately pulled out your phone and
did a live stream hey guys uh so
just want to let you know i just peed my
pants um yeah a lot of pee just all over
the pants just
pretty embarrassing thought i should let
you know okay see you later bye
i don't understand the point i don't see
why you would do that um and but we ask
who would do this except to be funny
well the answer is narcissists
narcissists who think that every moment
of their lives
needs to be out there and observed by
everyone who think that everything they
do
and everything they think and say and
feel is profound and important and
worthy of attention uh who think that
every moment of their lives every event
is is is nothing more than an
opportunity to gain more attention
for themselves those are the kinds of
people who do this
just total narcissists and there are a
lot of those out there and so there are
a lot of these types of videos
number six uh we'll do a bonus number
six here finally bonus content i want to
show you a video made by some friends of
ours uh i think this
kind of shows you what we're up against
ch check it out
said you can give me anything
what you looking for man maybe this
ain't a typical request
look bro i can get whatever you need
guns drugs women
you're gambling man you like that hard
stuff you need somebody to go away
look you got cash i make things happen
[Music]
baby parts what'd you say
you heard me unborn human baby parts
sickle i thought you can get anything
what'd it look like to you planned
parenthood
you know it's a joke but it's it's not
at the same time this is what planned
parenthood does and
was caught doing and yet half a billion
dollars
half a billion dollars every year
from the taxpayer and it does
almost still shock me almost
that these people were caught on tape
and the tapes are still there you can
see them on youtube selling human body
parts
the body parts of babies on tape
laughing about it
we saw these videos not deceptively
edited by the way that's a myth that's a
lie
planned parenthood did their own
forensic analysis of those tapes
that were done by dave deliden in the
center for medical progress and they
themselves admitted that they were not
substantially edited
in any way that's manipulative or
deceptive they admitted that in their
own report
go look that up too and so this is all
on tape and yet uh nobody talks about it
anymore like it never happened
and still the half a billion dollars
keeps funneling every year
from your pockets into theirs
with no sign of stopping if it didn't
stop with a democrat congress or
rather a republican congress and a
republican president it's not ever going
to stop
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content